stop
[Music]
crash bandicoot bill Potter Oh aspire at
the dragon what's your impression of him
I'm spiring the dragon yeah sure these
are two beloved PlayStation mascots from
back in the day they've obviously both
been reignited or insane
remastered for ps4 Xbox one but the
intro the thing that I'm most interested
in will is how do these games stand up
today because at their core both of
these remaster trilogies are still 20
year old a set of 20 year old video
games right do they do they stand up to
today's modern standards I think the
biggest surprise for me go Mets a crash
in particular because I loved Crash
Bandicoot back in the day as all my
favorite games on the PlayStation it's a
harder this yeah I don't think I've got
worse games I mean that might also be
true maybe it's possible I have aged I'm
an old man now but I think a lot of
people played mostly crash 2 & 3 I
missed a lot of crash 1 which is meant
to be the hardest game yeah so if you
start the insane trilogy as most people
do in a 1 2 3 order you're going to
start with the hardest one and which is
quite a shock to the system so I
remember this being fun I don't remember
this being really hard and unforgiving
yeah and less so you threw out 2 & 3 I
think but it is the theme of crash that
it's a bit more of a hardcore platformer
definitely way less forgiving than Spyro
do you agree I did yeah I do agree yeah
the crash is definitely hard to go back
to you know but it's still a great great
set of games I think they're cool yeah
Spyro I think probably is just more
similar to the kind of games that we
would play today is in the I think it's
it's a lot more open it's a lot more
forgiving with its platforming and its
enemies you know realistically the
enemies are a case of you either fire
breathed on them or you charge through
them it doesn't get much more
complicated than that really
and I think that the levels lend
themselves so a lot more exploration
whereas the crash bandicoot levels even
in two and three where things open up a
little bit more it's still very linear
you're going down one corridor sometimes
that might fork into two paths but at
the end of the day it's crashes a much
simpler set of games and I think that
doesn't help the feeling that it's more
it feels more dated than the Spyro
trilogy I see what you mean yeah like I
was playing a level where you have to
jump forwards as crash and in that it's
a 3d space but you're it's still quite a
linear platformer so it's very hard to
judge that distance and if you're off
even slightly
you're dead and then you've got to start
back at the last checkpoint and you've
only got so many lies we have to start a
level all over again so the later levels
you might find yourself having to keep
retrying a retry and retrying and I was
surprised at how hard they got yeah
thing I do love about crash though is
the variety yeah it's not about saying
yeah it's not just platforming it's
riding a motorbike it's firing 1 per
fruit out of a rocket launcher it's
flying aeroplanes riding polar bears
yeah being chased by giant polar bears
there's a lot going on so it does break
away from that sort of standard
platforming game to a broader experience
with a lot more going on
[Music]
Spira has elements of that as well
yeah definitely I think if you look at
Spiro year the dragon is my favorite the
three and you've got companion missions
there you've got minigames where you're
on a skateboard trying to chase down
weird rap things I think that was the
demo back in the day it was yeah it was
yeah so there's there's definitely a lot
of variety and the right the variety
visually is incredible Spyro and that's
only been enhanced by this remaster
which I think both of them look
absolutely beautiful even though I think
Spyro probably stands up a little better
now I think they both are still very
very fun experiences particularly when
you look at them as complete packages I
think the original Spyro gamers in the
first one and the first crash bandicoot
game they feel quite dated now but I
think two and three of each respective
trilogy are still fantastic games yeah
for sure and actually I didn't really
play Spyro back on my original
PlayStation oh really I think I played
the demo because I used to collect the
PlayStation magazines and get the demo
discs but I never owned a spyro game so
this was my first time probably playing
spyro and it's amazing actually how well
it's held up it's really fun there was
mechanics in that game that I was
surprised that spyro can roll he can
breathe fire he can glide which all
feels like something you would find in a
platformer today
whereas crash is a bit more rigid and
just jump and it feels very difficult to
control not as fluid as spiral yeah I
think the best thing about Spyro the
reason why I do prefer it to crash even
though I do really like crash as well
the reason I prefer Spyro is that it
feels like more of an adventure and part
of that is because of the level design
but part of it is also because you get
to chat to the locals in each world and
that kind of gives it a sense of like it
feels like almost like a Pixar animated
film where you're going and chatting to
like these amazing weird creatures and
it's such a it's got a childlike
innocence to it that I know it's a very
it's an oft mentioned thing of nostalgia
but these games
Spyro in particular for me but both
games do bring me right back to my
childhood and I that's why I think both
of them are very special experiences
find the eggs and bring them back Spyro
you're our only chance you
[Music]
so both crash and Spyro have had a fresh
liquor paint with these new trilogies
we've talked about how they play and how
those hold up in that regard though
which one would you actually recommend
picking up today I think if you look at
the way these two trilogies have been
remastered I think they're both easy to
recommend in truth I think Spyro does
hold up better in terms of its gameplay
but I think if you look at the way I
mean toys for Bob and Vicarious Visions
have done amazing jobs in in making
these games fit for a modern audience
and fit for modern consoles as well like
they do look genuinely beautiful and
some of the some of the additions
they've made are fantastic and I think
one of my favorite touches as well is
for me having been slightly more of a
spirochete than a crash kid the
soundtrack was such a huge part of my
childhood and having the original
soundtrack in there as an option that
you can just toggle on and off is
amazing and I'm glad they've got that
because Stewart Coppens work on the
original trilogy is amazing
[Music]
they're both easy to recommend for
anyone who played crash a bunch as a kid
like definitely the insane trilogy is
worth picking up for anyone who played
spyro a bunch as a kid
the reignited trilogy is definitely
worth picking up I think if you were to
buy it for a child now I think crash
would probably be too difficult and not
modern enough in its underlying design
for most children now I think Spyro
lends itself to a modern audience much
better but they're both easy to
recommend yeah crushers more
straightforward platforming it gets hard
it gets punishing Spyro feels more like
an adventure yeah Spyro talks where his
crash is mute well yeah it's not mute he
says whoa okay fair enough but yeah
that's all you get out of him so it
feels like you're part of a bigger world
and a bigger story where crash is quite
lonely
apart from as few polar bear and tiger
companions and crash is also on switch
that's another thing to point out
hopefully Spyro does come to switch as
well because that is just the perfect
place to play a game like that yeah just
on the bus on the train commuting having
a platform like that is is the best
how many commuters have you scared by
going oh about 13 at this point and TfL
have lodged a formal complaint all right
guys that was our thoughts on the Spyro
reignited trilogy and the crash
bandicoot insane trilogy both of which
we think are great remastered trilogies
but let us know your thoughts on the two
trilogies in the comments below or you
can come find us on twitter i'm at their
said i'm at the cliff is dead thanks
very much for watching and we'll see you
next time
[Laughter]
[Music]
oh my arse is on camera